mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünschen ihnen viel vergnügen
sie sind vom tanzfieber ergriffen
schüler und schülerinnen beim züri dance
award
[Musik]
sie wird endlich weltweit gefeiert der
späte rung der schweizer künstlerin
sophie teuber ab und sie feiern die
gekrönten häupter dieser welt die
schweizer demokraten haben ein faible
für die royals kulturplatz heute
[Musik]
wir kommen auf den kulturplatz ja heute
entdecken wir die grosse schweizer
künstlerin sophie teuber art in ganz
neuem licht
hier im kunstmuseum basel wird klar wie
es toll war scheinbar spielerisch
schaffte die grenzen zwischen kunst und
alltäglichem leben aufzulösen
eine königin der heiterkeit und der
abstraktion so könnten wir sie nennen
[Musik]
nein
die
zu beginn der sendung geht es das erstes
nicht um die königin der abstraktion so
viel teurer sondern um echte königliche
hoheiten genauer gesagt um unser
verhältnis zu ihnen die schweiz das
angeblich demokratische land überhaupt
war und ist oft und gerne reiseziel von
gekrönten häuptern und wir uhr
demokratinnen und demokraten jubeln
ihnen begeistert zu
das zeigt aktuell das forum für
schweizer geschichte in schwyz
das thailändische königspaar kam in die
schweiz und die queen natürlich auch wie
ihre vor vor vor vor vorgängerin queen
victoria
für die dänische königin ingrid sahen
sogar der jogi clubs
prinz charles und lady 37 das skifahren
während haile selassie aus äthiopien in
die schweiz kam um waffen zu kaufen und
empfangen wurde wie ein kaiser die
schweiz liebt gekrönte häupter waren
sonst würde sich der gesamtbundesrat in
reih und glied für den spanischen könig
juan carlos auf stellen live im
fernsehen und bei strömendem regen
[Musik]
von dieser faszination der
demokratischen schweiz für er
undemokratische königinnen und kaiser
erzählt die ausstellung die royals
kommen die von der historikerin pia
schubiger im forum schweizer geschichte
in schwyz kuratiert wurde
das ist das paradox aber irgendwo ist es
auch verständlich demokratisches land
funktioniert das stück vielleicht
faszinierende titel von man ein
koenigshofer kreis erinnern können wo
jetzt die ganze geschichte damit
verbunden sind
das interessiert vielleicht genau blüht
wo das doch nicht als regierungsform
abitur also doch die heimliche sehnsucht
nach der großen geste nach pomp und
weltgeschehen
und natürlich das märchenhafte all der
tragödien und liebesgeschichten wie sie
nur prinzen und prinzessinnen zu erleben
scheinen von ihnen erzählt der
schriftsteller michael von poser sein
buch blaues blut liegt der ausstellung
zugrunde und liefert geschichten
anekdoten
und unbekannte hintergründe die spiele
sind wahnsinnig stolz auf die demokratie
und auf der anderen seite denn wenn ob
die wall street legt jetzt eine rolle
score sie zu füßen
sie bleibt nicht nur zu hunderte oder
zügiges und sozialwesen zu 100 usingen
geplatzt eine rolle zu wenn die schweiz
nicht
der besuch der englischen königin
victoria 1868 hinterließ so großen
eindruck dass plätze und hotels noch
immer ihren namen tragen
nach dem tod ihres ehemannes versank sie
in trauer wollte allein sein und mal die
schweiz als rückzugsort
ganz andere motive hatte der deutsche
kaiser deutsche kaiser wilhelm tesch
1912 die zum staatsbesuch und deutungen
ermöglicht es besonders exponat vor dem
staatsbesuch name erfolg bahn und auto
schiff
die körperpflege war teil seines medial
inszenierten auftritt als feldherr
sein besuch wird ausführlich gefilmt und
dient der vorbereitung des ersten
weltkriegs wilhelm besucht ein manöver
um sich von der wehrhaftigkeit der
schweizer armee zu überzeugen für den
fall eines krieges gegen den erzfeind
frankreich
wie stark die liaison zwischen den
hoheiten und der boulevardpresse schon
damals war zeigt die ausstellung am
beispiel von königin astrid von belgien
sie war die lady drei der 1930 er jahre
und verunglückte auf der panoramastraße
am vierwaldstätter see tödlich
ein zufällig vorbeikommender student
fotografierte als erster das unglück von
105 betriebs gemacht hat wenn er als
eine vorschau auf die unfallstelle
königin paparazzo wurde und dass es
eigentlich werden um die fotos den
zeitungen und agenturen in aller welt
zur verfügung zu stellen
riskiert die swissair den ersten
nachtflug von dübendorf nach london flog
auf staatsschulden das fahrrad nimmt die
bilder zacke freistoß nach löcher landen
auf die redaktion vor unterstrich die
bildung von der welt und mit dem 19
daher nach die bild die ganze welt
verteilen und kreationen klingen und dem
early morning die ich im ganzen welt
sind tierfutter sowie die rock
die kapelle die am unfallort errichtet
wurde musste 1960 verschoben werden
zu viele menschen wollten am ufer des
vierwaldstättersees der belgischen
königin astrid gedenken teil haben vom
tragischen tod dieser königin der herzen
idee dass man es teilt allwissend hören
wo heim bestickt war da dort und wisla
wo man so spielt ganz was anderes ist
das fasziniert einfach die faszination
am royal im land der direkten demokratie
lang lebe der widerspruch
[Musik]
wir sind zurück hier im kosmos der
sophie taeuber arp im kunstmuseum basel
eine der wichtigsten schweizer
künstlerinnen des 20 jahrhunderts und
obwohl ihr konterfei jahre lang unsere
50er note prägte geriet ihr werk über
lange zeit in vergessenheit
sophie taeuber-arp wächst auf den
tiefsten appenzell und ruben als kind
einer wohlhabenden textil dynastie
früh schon interessierte sich für
textile handwerk net kostüme und nutzt
stoffe für erste künstlerische
ausdrucksformen
[Musik]
die textilen muster führen sie schnell
zur abstrakten malerei
[Musik]
nach ihrer ausbildung in deutschland
lernt sie in zürich den künstler hans
arp kennen und wird während des ersten
weltkrieges teil der dada-bewegung im
umfeld dieser freigeister beginnt sie zu
experimentieren und kombiniert hans
textilien und skulpturen ihre kunst und
der flache design führen sie nach
straßburg wo sie zusammen mit hans arp
ihr größtes räumliches vermächtnis
erschafft die opec ein vergnügungslokal
dessen innendekoration sie mit ihm
entwirft
[Musik]
mit dem honorar der robert baut sie ein
haus in der nähe von paris
heute ein museum hier entstehen ihre
wichtigsten kunstwerke
der zweite weltkrieg treibt sie dann in
die flucht zuerst südfrankreich tan
zürich wo sie 1943 mit 54 jahren stirbt
sie sind die kuratorin dieser
ausführlichen werk schaffung sophie
teuber ab hier sehen wir auch die
marionetten die sie schuf 1918 wofür
standen sie damals ich glaube das sind
wirklich artistische kunstwerke die den
zeitgeschmack auch herausgefordert haben
marionetten waren damals eher
geschnitzte werke und hier sind sie
gedrechselt deswegen auch diese ganz
geometrische formensprache sowie treiber
ab hat im nachhinein dann selbst gesagt
die leute hätten sie als extrem gewagt
und modernen empfunden
und man darf glaube ich auch nicht
vergessen dass sie vor dem hintergrund
eines tobenden weltkrieges entstanden
sind und einer tobenden grippe pandemie
also es sind werke die uns heute fast
wie eine art vorahnung erscheinen wenn
man sich alleine mal diese woche
anschaut diese militärische einheit die
waltons heute an kampfroboter oder sowas
denken lässt die große werkschau ist
eine kooperation mit new york und london
nun statt die ausstellung in barßel ein
glücksfall für gestalt ein glücksfall
für die schweiz aber ich glaube auch
etwas bitter süß denn wir hätten
wahnsinnig gerne diesen moment in new
york gefeiert es geht ja zunächst mit
dieser retrospektive darum dass dafür
teuber ab ihren ersten internationalen
auftritt hat zum ersten mal
international wirklich gesehen wird auch
im englischsprachigen raum vor allem das
kann man fast nicht glauben dass ich es
so es ist ziemlich unglaublich
ein und 2021 es musste dieses jahr
werden um diesen internationalen
auftritt zu haben genau nehmen wir einen
blickfang der ausstellung gehen wir
einmal sehr gerne danke
[Musik]
könnte man sich das auch gemacht und auf
dem einigen sucht frau stand
[Musik]
ja das ist auch eines dieser werke da
sieht man das architektonische denken
dass wir so eine art blick von oben auf
dem grundriss
übergehen müssen das wirft blasen aber
das ändern wir das war ich glaube meine
persönlichen lieblings bilder ja wie das
ist ein traum nach das werk
und das ist stabil ist und trotzdem
irgendwie ja genau ein labiles
gleichgewicht könnte man sagen so viel
teurer aber mit dem künstler hans
verheiratet wie funktioniert die beiden
zusammen ich glaube die haben sich
wunderbar ergänzt dass es gab so eine
art marketing abteilung bei ihnen glaube
ich und dann vielleicht so er das
pragmatische einer hat die verbindungen
hergestellt und so viel teurer ab hat
eben auch ganz stark darauf geachtet
dass die kunst bekannt wurde und zum
beispiel dafür gesorgt dass kataloge in
die usa geschickt wurden also auch so
ein sehr praktisches und sehr vorwärts
denken das herangehen eigentlich an
diesen job so viel teurer ab hat sich ja
von der kunsthandwerkerin zur künstlerin
entwickelt wie verlief dieser weg also
ich glaube dieser weg spannt sich
eigentlich zwischen den kunstzentren von
zürich während des ersten weltkrieges
und danach bis nach paris in den 30er
jahren
sie ist zuerst kunsthandwerkerinnen und
eben da ist die künstlerin in diesen in
diesem brodelnden avantgarde leben in
zürich und dann in den 30er jahren als
sie sich in paris niedergelassen haben
ist sie eine freischaffende abstrakte
künstlerin und war sie auch eine
politische künstlerin
na ja politisch hieß in den 30er jahren
ja schon wenn man abstrakt malte dass
man sich einer formensprache bediente
die von den diktatorischen regime in der
sowjetunion und in deutschland nicht
mehr gutgeheissen wurde und aus den
museen entfernt wurde also von daher
reichte es schon abstrakte künstlerin zu
sein um das wie eine art politische
äußerung zu verstehen ihr leben nahm
dann auch ein viel zu frühes brutales
ende ja sie haben dort eines abends als
es spät geworden war eben beide bei max
bill übernachtet sie im gästezimmer und
der ofen dessen abzugeben noch
geschlossen war der hat dann eine
kohlenmonoxid-vergiftung verursacht und
sie ist in einer kalten januarnacht im
schlaf gestorben
ganz herzlichen dank für diese einblicke
in das leben der sophie torbereich sehr
gern danke
[Musik]
jetzt von einem großen nicht mehr
lebenden talent zu ganz jungen
quicklebendigen teenager auf der ganzen
welt sind verbunden durch eine app
namens tik tok und dort wird ein virus
befeuert der tanzfieber heißt ein kanton
und ein guter song
und schon ist die tanzeinlage fertig und
auf tik tok gepostet
für teenager ist die social media ab tik
tok die rettung in zeiten wo alles
andere verboten war
[Gelächter]
die tik tok sind auch die grundlage für
den ersten großen tanzauftritt nachdem
lockte im zürcher schulhaus
hirschengraben proben die future girls
dafür seit monaten
noch ist nicht alles perfekt synchron
sich schwierig und dass man mit seele
muss und dass man sich nicht ablenken
und alle anderen fällen auch einen so
mich sind die badesachen schon noch li
und sind auch werde ich glaube dass wir
am samstagmorgen haben wir glaube ich
und ich glaube dass mit show
die choreo braucht noch den letzten
schliff vor dem großen auftritt
[Musik]
ein paar tage später im volkshaus zürich
hier findet der züri dance statt 26
schulklassen kämpfen in drei kategorien
darum die beste show zu liefern
corona bedenkt werden die klassen
einzeln durchgeschleust
ohne publikum
dafür wird live gestreamt
45 minuten vor ihrem auftritt dürfen
auch die mädchen der ersten
sekundarklasse hirschengraben ins
volkshaus
erst einmal werden die gegner gecheckt
[Applaus]
dann fototermin kommen sie aufs podest
braucht es ein gutes foto
noch 15 minuten bis zum auftritt
bisher nervös sie hatte noch nie in der
aufführung gehabt aber also ohne
publikum ist glaubt ein bisschen besser
deswegen bin ich nicht so nervös wie ich
eigentlich sein sollte
fünf minuten vor ihrem auftritt dürfen
sie endlich in die halle
[Musik]
jetzt kann es losgehen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ist die show vorbei müssen die teenager
wieder an die luft corona bedingt findet
die preisverleihung nicht im volkshaus
sondern virtuell statt
werden sie gewinnen
die spannung steigt wir sind besser war
der zweite rang
es hat sich gelohnt hoffen wir dass es
bald mehr solche auftritte geben kann
mit publikum
[Musik]
stellen sie sich mal vor ein schweizer
kreiert für die allergrößten filmstars
seinerzeit die filmkostüme von marlon
brando bist marlene dietrich zudem
kreierte das erscheinungsbild der
swissair unser aller nationalstolz
vergangener zeiten
romy bär nannte sich der mann der selbst
zu so etwas wie einem star wurde nur
heute
heute kennt den modeschöpfer niemand
mehr eine entdeckung
seine kleider machten stars
und lieferten den stoff für ein
bühnenreifes leben
hinter den kulissen ich bin der rächer
weltstadt bürger verfahren welt aber ich
bin in sankt annen aufgewachsen und
enthusiastisch drein seiner lernen sie
immer gerne passt raffiniert und der
wollte die er 1975 erzählt zum studium
der malerei in die stadt der mode in
paris ist der huber wurde
es ist dieser über her beginnt kostüme
zu entwerfen lernt so gloria swanson
kennen und geht mit der stummfilm ikone
vor 100 jahren nach hollywood als ihr
ganz persönlicher designer
eine ausstellung im zürcher museum für
gestaltung widmet sich nun erstmals dem
schweizer der von 1895 bis 1976 lebt im
relegant immer star
das ist eine kette von arbeit sie aber
im grund natürlich ein enormes vermögen
und eine enorme accent wenn man das
fortan kreiert über kleider für die
großen filmstudios
die sie gebührend in szene setzen wie
hier mit vivian leigh der oscar
preisträgerin aus vom winde verweht
für die kostüme in desiree erhält könne
er 1954 selbst eine oscar nominierung
[Musik]
im film verkörpert marlon brando
napoleon und gene simmons dessen
jugendliebe die nicht weniger als 35
kleider zur schau trägt
[Musik]
zehn jahre später wird rüde über erneut
für den oscar nominiert nun für gewisse
mit ingrid bergman und anthony quinn
eine adaption des dürrenmatt stücks der
besuch der alten dame das damals noch
junge breitbildformat benötigt bei
massenszenen mehr figuren und damit mehr
kostüme reiz und tücke zugleich für ihn
kommt der moment nicht wieder kein
academy award dennoch bleibt sie
ausgezeichnet seine lange karriere in
der traumfabrik genauso wie in der film
theater musical und modewelt europas das
wird dem designer dieser kleider gut
getan haben denn als homosexueller kennt
er anfeindungen
in der öffentlichkeit ist er schlicht
der renommierte kreierte
so kann er etwa in der schweiz kostüme
für die landesausstellung 1939 entwerfen
oder ein terrier und kollektionen für
die nationale fluggesellschaft
die swissair hat den knoten ihres jura
dessen in neuer uniform vorgestellt wer
jetzt nicht zum fliegen lust hat dem ist
nicht mehr zu helfen
was sonst hat er in uniform besonders
schön und praktisch also mit fraktion es
gut bedient somit wäre ich also sehr
gefreut haben und erträgt wir falls
bundes gute blaupause mit einem herzigen
geraten unter stress ist eine mit lecker
wie die vision wird fraktion das gute
bläser mit dem rufe er und der ball
akkurat es im alltag klammer auf der
leinwand in den 60er jahren endete über
schaffen für den film mit 70 und nach
rund 200 produktionen beidseits des
atlantiks was ich malen dietrich
im gegensatz zur extravaganten freundin
gerät der mann hinter den kulissen
zusehens in vergessenheit
trotz großer verdienste
und was sich diese ganze große traum
hollywood überhaupt sie eine ganz
fantastische welt so zinner zieht mit
großen glamour und mit wundervollen
statiker herrlicher kleider was dazu
wollte ich zu viel arbeit und viel geld
jahre nach seinem tod wird rüde über er
in die ruhmeshalle des kostüm designs
aufgenommen
kleider machen neben stars
die schweizer schauspielerin lilo pulver
feiert dieses jahr ihren 92
geburtstag vielleicht erinnern sie sich
vor zwei jahren unser besuch bei einer
ewig jung wirkenden 90-jährigen lilo
jetzt bekommt sie den schweizer
filmpreis für ihr lebenswerk wir
gratulieren
außerdem nominiert ist die schweizer
regisseurin güzin kar und zwar mit einem
kurzfilm der unter die haut geht
das ist eine straße so lapidar beginnt
güssing als kurzfilm ein filmisches
denkmal gewidmet der vierjährigen cm
denn die 1993 aus einem dieser fenster
in den tod sprang weil neonazis im
deutschen solingen das haus ihrer
türkischen familie in brand gesteckt
hatten
ich habe mich damals schon gefragt
müssten wir als filme rinnen und
fielmann nicht irgendwie uns dazu
verhalten
ich wusste aber nicht wie märkte dann
aber jetzt so vor zwei jahren das ist
doch aktuell wird ich suchte nach einer
form
das ergebnis dieser suche ist dieser
film
er zeigt die straße die nach ihm benannt
wurde
sonst nichts und erzählt von dem toten
mädchen leise und zärtlich in der nacht
zum 29 mai 1993 schreck das duo aus dem
schlaf weil euer haus brannte der
nachbar und seine freunde hatten es
angezündet
die straße die nach ihm benannte ist
liegt nicht im zentrum einer stadt nicht
dort wo sie auffallen würde sondern im
urbanen niemandsland
das macht den film so traurig und so
wichtig weil er den mord an dem mädchen
sei mit dem vergessen entreißt du
würdest vier jahre alt andere in deinem
alter bekommen fahrräder oder puppen
spucken
du hast eine straße nur weil du tot bist
[Musik]
ja da tanzen die puppen von sophie
teuber ab an der fassade des
kunstmuseums basel
die ausstellung läuft bis juni die
verleihung der schweizer filmpreise wird
diesen freitag gestreamt sie können also
auch live mit dabei sein
nächste woche dort zeigen wir ihnen das
sehr persönliche fotografische
zeitdokument einer mutter und gleich
jetzt führt er auf sf1 die serie vor sie
würden kommen sie gut durch die woche
[Musik]
bei coop ab
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos
[Musik]